[Musique]
bonjour bon appétit je vais mettre un
petit peu de villes comme ça dans le
linge est un tout petit peu rapide
alors oui les brochettes l'un cette
brochette je ne m'habille pas des
desserts et je vais faire lors de va
faire on va mettre les brochettes à
cuire parce que qu'est ce qui est sûr c
est bien il y a de lannion de l'épaule
d'agneau il ya dit éloignons d'agneau il
y à du foie d'agneau
il ya des feuilles de laurier il y a il
va y avoir remercié l'alternance il vous
propose l'achat cette fois un morceau
grenier il faut commencer et finir par
quelque chose de solide
serge aliments un morceau c'est quoi du
loriot laurier ouais c'était laurier
sauce bien sûr tous cas votre source
oui ou alors là on m a droit
voilà et dont on ne mange pas une seule
personne ne mange pas une brochette y
aussi on serait il s'agit d' une recette
du maïs à idées votre habitude s'est
vidé alors un peu de sel sur les
brochettes envahi mettre également un
peu d'épicés d'herbes pulvérisé la couse
à l'avant la gentillesse de me faire
passer mais c'est fait et c'est de
l'amour seul gagne on assiste encore en
vacances et sur le barbecue si on a la
chance d'en avoir je m'en veux déranger
un tout petit peu mieux
on va retourner à celle qui est donc
plus à bouger et va brûler en face à
fait rien la csu la boule rock on la
[Musique]
regarde moi je vais rester là non bien
marquer ça peut vous rendre là voilà et
voilà bien alors c'est parti
ces parts et puis de donner la leçon à
son affaire soit il ment non ça va ça va
griller pendant que nous nous allons
nous occuper de la frontière l'arrêt
chose étrange voix du raisin du raisin
et je vois dollar grimpant ensemble
c'était si cet ensemble justement c'est
ainsi qu'est ce qu'ils racontent
n'importe quoi
eh bien voyez-vous je crois que là nous
pouvons parler de cuisine paléolithique
c'est le cas de dire vous immédiate
alors oui j'aime bien parler parce que
c'est vraiment la simplicité des
simplicité autrefois on est jamais ça ne
sort pas du tout et bien maintenant nous
avons deux solutions possibles
la solution du pain de campagne n'est ce
pas europe 1 c'est ça fait c'est plus la
solution du peur la pagaie allons nous
allons utiliser les deux si vous voulez
bien pour que chacun puisse choisir la
façon dont il joue nous ont le temps
alors on va prendre un morceau de près
ceci selon notre plaisir
selon mon appétit et puis on va pas
également un quignon de pain ici sur
celui ci en qui n'y ont jamais parlé de
double oui non mais c'est pas ce que je
veux je veux faire le quignon alors
voilà deux morceaux de peur ces deux
morceaux de pain nous allons les
protéger
ça semble d'une grande banalité et
pourtant c'est vraiment mais pas le dire
par 2,1 de ses plats célèbre en de
s'aimer passait pas à me placer c'est un
véritable repas le repas du vendangeur
bordelais n'est ce pas pendant un an et
ça c'est tout à fait ça le matin dans la
vigne alors évidemment il peut emporter
du raisin lors il s'agit de deux trous
trous raisin mais il vaut mieux aller le
cueillir on pourrait presque les le
brouter pour ainsi dire pas serait
merveilleux alors du sel de l'huile
d'olive
c'est absolument très important et
voyous elle et les vignerons chez nous
dans le bordelais il emporte la petite
bouteille d'huile
le petit paquet de sel et le morceau de
pain avec l'ail
en fait nous voir ce qu'ils enfants
alors facile et les parents
déjà nos jeunes amis verront ça n'a
tellement bon qu'est ce que tu fais tu
emportes une bouteille d'huile un
guignol et au home est un morceau n'a
envie de lui comme ça et puis on frotte
on frotte la croûte du pain comme ça
avec like you avec lui aussi est ce que
vous nous avez fait ça avec lui avec la
campagne en aquitaine ont bien joué
autrement dit le pain bagnat qui est
également une recette alors là c'est une
relance un provençal mais est également
là la recette qui vient de la nuit des
temps je vous disais quand je vous ai
parlé de magna je vous ai dit que il
était probable que c'était le super un
s'être l'aïeul du sandwich nous il a
effectivement c'est un saint louis se
fait mme magnien hélas ce n'est pas un
stand with u tous et ceux du plan qui a
été préparé
alors il faut il faut d'abord lui les ai
ensuite le saler légèrement
et bien alors on peut on doit continuer
car ils portent à oui il faut absolument
que l'huile soit bien soit bien
imprégnant les seins avant de partir ou
à jamais de la vie la vie sur l'a10
offert ça on va les bleuets mont noir au
tout dernier moment beaucoup
d'imagination vous allez goûter avec la
halloween où vous prenez la grappe de
raisin geste inconsidéré
non mais au fola alors on m'a jamais mme
la grappe et hommage au père maintenant
la voix fait voir vraiment comment ça et
puis le temps voilà
et ça en même temps et ça ça vous paraît
pas un peu paradoxal
mario mais à tout le monde mais rue
champollion le plaisir que j'y prends
c'est d'ailleurs c'est d'ailleurs une
méthode que j'ai toujours vu pratiquer
chez moi depuis toujours et est avec ce
vieux avec le receveur avec 16 aux
vieilles méthodes à fabriquer le pain il
est évident que si délicieux mais ne
croyez pas pour autant qu'aux lignes
celui ci ne soit pas bon c'est excellent
alors on peut et nous le faisons
maintenant de plus en plus nous fondons
comme ceux ci le pain de légèrement
on émet une goutte d'huile dedans comme
ceux ci ça alors là on rejoint d'amiens
ont rejoint le poignant et puis à
l'extérieur on refait tout ce que j'ai
fait tout à l'heure vous êtes dessus
dans le train venir vous faisiez dessous
oui alors le fait au tout autour à tout
oui parce que là l'importance de laillé
comme s'il n'y a rien d'autre
non y'a rien à l'intérieur il faut qu'il
y ait beaucoup beaucoup d'ail
car je vous dirais que c'est qu'être
curieux et ce qui est important à mon
avis vous savez que si vous ne voulez
pas sentir là et après en avoir mangé
une méthode excellente consiste à manger
du piercing or pourquoi du persil parce
que c'est très riche en en chlorophylle
mais leurs raisins apporte à peu près le
même à peu près sûr que ça n'a pas si
bien que ça n'a pas la langue au gagnant
de sentir la et à longueur de vie je pas
ou de journée alors vous faites une
photo live vous allez vous allez voir ce
que vous allez vous y mettre
je suis je comprends mieux la boue de
tamise tout à l'air du raisin comme ça
alors effectivement je trouve ça c'est
très joli d'ailleurs le fait de manger
la grappe concert de manger de mordre
dans la grave ça ça a un côté champêtre
un côté sylvestre extraordinaire polluer
retourner les brochettes en attendant
nous c'est vraiment une danse est bien
celle que vous nous avez donné
aujourd'hui et je ne sais pas si elle
elle plaira à tous mais ils n'ont qu'à y
goûter je suis sûr que là je suis sûr
qu'ils la trouveront délicieuse parce
que pour ne rien vous cacher la vérité
je l'avais déjà goûté et bien répond je
veux raconter ce que vous avez fait la
voile avait goûté oui vous l'avez vous
tes dents chez roule en voiture dans la
jeune dans votre jeunesse enfin ça ya
très très longtemps derrière et lorient
je crois qu'il est temps maintenant de
songer à clore ce petit interlude
interlude gastronomique et vous avez
venir nous montrer si votre brochettes
et à tout ceux qui sauront [ __ ] dans
quelques secondes
et ce sera effectivement peut être
qu'aujourd'hui de recettes l'abaya
duflot
vraiment les liens de ces chais de
l'agneau à tiroirs oignons et paul
d'agneau avec deux rouges à laurier 2
feuilles de laurier entre chaque morceau
c'est lui seul et c'est tout à fait un
petit peu sur un petit peu d'herbe
devons avancer comme ça dessus pour les
faire cuire et alors là frottés à l'ail
en place si vous avez de l'appétit et
bien je crois que là du coup on peut
vraiment vous dire que l'appétit
[Musique]